by the power of castle hate skull i am
hello mark harley and i am so grateful
you're back here with me for another
absolute banger if i don't say so myself
precognitively
in advance of this episode even being
recorded it's coming in hot i'm coming
in hot we got so many good segments
today we got let's see we're going to
talk about workout stuff we're going to
talk about um psychedelics we might even
talk about some anabolics we might look
at some gym fails we might look at some
memes all these things and more on
today's episode of haters we'll say
episode 31 with hella mark harley all
right
so
guys i just wanted to start off hot as i
said as i previewed i told you i wasn't
going to start like normal i'm going to
come in
[Laughter]
piping hot it's burning my mouth in fact
so i gotta get it out now i gotta spit
it out we're starting with hey that
hurts
as you may know if you follow me on
social medias i posted a photo the other
day
of me at zoo culture taken by a fellow
named christian who shoots a lot of
sketches for me and isaiah
i thought it was pretty good turns out
some people had some negative things to
say about me and i just wanted to start
with this up front to remind everyone
that i am in fact a human being i have
feelings um you say mean things to me on
the internet sometimes i'll pretend like
they don't bother me but in fact it is
hurtful to me and i do experience
negative emotions surrounding this sort
of criticism of my physical appearance
so
here's just you know i
i collected some of these comments i
curated them
at some point i had to stop because it
does wear on my psyche um so this was
just a selection off the top of the
first 20 to 30 comments that i saw but
there were more maybe we'll cover them
in another episode but this was all i
can handle
hey look santa got dumped by mrs claus
and started abusing human growth hormone
what's it called when someone's having a
mid-life crisis but they're 60 a
pre-death crisis
mean
if i leave protein pancakes instead of
cookies this year will he leave tren in
my stocking
this answers the question what if the
witcher was 60 years old and had down
syndrome
he didn't get the memo that passed a
certain percentage of gray hair it's no
longer a man bun it's a grand bun
his abs are almost as asymmetrical as
his face
proof that working out a lot doesn't
always make you look better
he looks like a giant penis that's on
the prowl for giant penis
how long did it take for the cops to
come escort that guy out of zoo culture
sir the court order says you have to
stay a hundred yards away from the 21
year old influencers come with us
every time he spoke to another lifter at
zoo that day the sentence started with
back in my day we didn't have fancy
weight rooms like this i'm just i'm
assuming they intended for my voice to
be like a grandma grandpa voice
he looks like the type of guy who would
get a bbl i would if i felt like i
needed it i do have hip dips
he's pretty ripped i don't know what has
more striations his packs his shoulders
or his face is that a wrinkle joke i
don't like it
this is what a cry for help looks like
he'll tell you he hasn't gone to
thanksgiving in 10 years to stick to his
diet but really it's because his family
doesn't like him
told the photographer make me look young
the photographer said got you fam you
about to look just like carl young
can we show what carl jung looks like
because i feel like that's it's an
unfair criticism if we're gonna
compare me to somebody maybe we should
just
uh-huh there we go
that picture right there
that's what i'm talking about this guy
do i really look like him i mean aside
from the gray hair okay maybe he's got a
point let's just put it away i can't
handle it liver king meme of the week oh
my god
so i guess liver king's doing like this
primal scream challenge
you know of course he is because
i it's just it's going to be interesting
to see how long this this goes on like
how long is liver king going to be a
thing you know
he's going to make it through the year
is it going to be two years three years
how much daily content you know are we
going to be drawn to how how far can he
take it right so this challenge here if
we click on that video right there
[Applause]
[Music]
primal roar now it's your turn sharon
tag me and your story and we'll be
reposting the most dominant roles
so okay this is
probably my favorite page just because
they're like 90 devoted to making fun of
the liver king uh not underscore fit
memes
you guys are awesome and hilarious and
they you know a lot of times they just
take his videos and
use the high-pitched voice on it but it
works and uh
so the follow-up to that liver king meme
of the week is this little picture right
there the first thing you see
uh tacking after attacking liver king in
your primal roar video
a divorce petition boom got him
okay so that pretty much covers
everything
for the entire podcast goodbye no
i wanted to start a part with those fun
things so we can get into some more
serious stuff and i don't feel bad about
boring you guys
sup fool this is the section in case you
didn't know where i talk about what's up
with me
and uh you know
that could be a range of things from
what i've been ingesting intellectually
to what i've been doing who i've been
seeing
here's something that you guys might not
know i had pizza three days in a row
last week started oh my god i know i
look in the mirror on sunday and i
didn't have any abs and i was like what
happened oh right i ate pizza three days
in a row um
but it can happen that quickly and i
think a lot of it's just water weight
but you know these are always things to
keep in mind as a general principle that
uh your appearance can change
drastically when you you know eat a
bunch of carbs and and to not freak out
but part of my brain i admit goes like
oh my god you're fat and panicked yeah
i'm fat right now i've been uh slamming
uh pasta and wine yeah
that'll do it it's great i mean it's
awesome but you can you can only sustain
that for so long and then like ah [ __ ]
yeah i just feel like the general thing
that i try to do is like all right i had
that you know well just to recount it
we had pizza in the office on friday as
a sort of uh celebration
that's what got me
looking back yeah the pizza party that's
yeah that's what kicked it off and i
definitely had a lot of pieces of pizza
and i usually don't drink but i had a
couple beers uh in the shui and then i
met up with my buddy tony on saturday at
this vegan spot but vegan food would
deceive you because it's like oh my god
it's vegan it's healthy but it's like
well it is all carbs you know that that
meatball that you're eating the it was
like a vegan italian place so
it's all pizza
it's uh
eggplant parmesan we had some desserts
too it was all great i would say the
weirdest thing was in fact the meatball
it's like crumbling in front of you and
you're like you know that was the one
thing i'm like i'm pretending to enjoy
eating this but i really don't um
everything else was great
and uh
it was cool to see my boy tony he was in
town
great guy he gave me some
uh
mushroom micro dose pills
and that's going to segue into a
conversation that you know we've talked
about psychedelics hella psychedelic
let's put it up there let's just bring
it in and say what we're actually doing
and not skirt around the fact that we
talk about psychedelics here on the
podcast so he gave me some of these
pills
and uh that was on saturday and i woke
up on sunday just feeling kind of tired
and groggy took a pill
and
i just wanted to report the subjective
experience because we talked about i've
talked about my preference for lsd
over mushrooms and various people have
have expressed their preferences to me a
lot of people do like mushrooms over lsd
um or vice versa but
um
you know that is
one of the things that's difficult about
mushrooms is
by getting the exact weight
so weighing it out how you take it i've
just had more inconsistent experiences
with mushrooms and that's kind of the
heart of it is what i have lsd
this the experience always seems to be
the same
now
when i took this microdose pill what i
really want to get at is
reporting
my experience of it from the time i took
it about half an hour later
that feeling of grogginess went away
i felt like
my mood went from sort of like dull and
unmotivated to
a desire to move around
a general increase in my mood so i went
from like
neutral or sad to happy
and
uh i generally felt like
because i normally wake up each day and
part of how i measure my subjective
experience of life is like am i thinking
of ideas am i like able to go
like
i have creative problems that i want to
solve like you know thinking of stuff
for the podcast or
you know anything else that i'm working
on and is my brain in that place because
sometimes it isn't if you're like in a
low mood or you're just feeling like
you know depressed or anxious or any one
of a number of unpleasant emotions it's
kind of hard to be creative in my
experience and so taking that one
microdose pill and the dose is
supposedly 0.18 to 0.22 grams and by
comparison
like a strong dose of mushrooms might be
you know people will talk about eighths
taking an eighth of an ounce which is
3.5 grams um
i think you could get pretty high off
like 2 grams you know 1.52 grams would
get you that experience but like a
liftoff dose would be 3.5 33.5
or more you know five you can really
like that would be a very strong
psychedelic experience but so we're
talking about you know a fifth of a gram
basically
so
i was impressed with it i instantly was
like wow that that is a that's a
noticeable difference um it worked as
sort of an instant antidepressant but
not in the same exact way as say
like
taking a stimulant that where you're
like all right i know i'm like up and
about and kind of have a sort of
jittery energy that doesn't necessarily
come along with a
mood enhancement effect caffeine can
sometimes do that but like a caffeine or
an adderall type of stimulant
like
there's
it's not necessarily like a happy
feeling and i would notice that it's
like with with a micro dose of mushrooms
there's a more distinct feeling of
happiness but it's also a you do have a
stimulatory effect
akin to taking a cup or two of coffee so
um
i thought that was really interesting
and it made me think more about stuff
that i've mentioned before in the
podcast which is the idea of
ssris
versus psychedelics in the use of anti
uh you know depressant medication and
specifically elon musk has been on
twitter recently
talking [ __ ] he's been talking all this
[ __ ] and uh
specifically he's been talking about
uh you know big pharma ssri has been
very critical
of ssris he said wellbutrin which is a
dopamine reuptake inhibitor
um
is more dangerous than adderall which is
a very interesting and kind of bold
statement that i'd like to look into
more but
you know suffice it to say if you follow
this kind of thing he was going off
right
and it made me want to look into more of
these claims that you know
that we talked on before with dr rhonda
patrick et cetera where the notion is
these two things do the same thing one
might be better than the other
and
uh this guy leo and longevity who have
talked about on the podcast several
times before and has this great channel
for
you know
anything nootropic related like putting
substances in your body to you know
essentially like a it's a biohacking
channel that's probably the best way to
put it part of that is is longevity
because you want like you're biohacking
in order to have longevity but it could
be for mental performance or these other
things or even sports performances and
elements of biohacking but it's not
strictly any one of those things so
i put on a video
on the way over here that was talking
about um the
you know a one-to-one comparison of
ssris and microdosing psilocybin
it's also interesting to hear from him
because unlike somebody like elon musk
or somebody else you might encounter
online who has a sort of anti-pharma or
anti-ssri bias and i understand there
are a lot of things to be critical of
especially the implementation of
antidepressants rather than like
you know
using a more holistic approach where
ssris might be part of the treatment but
people will hop on ssris and do nothing
else and then the outcomes aren't as
good but to say that they're not
effective in any way i think is unfair
however i listened to this video and
thought it was really enlightening as
far as
what ssris do and what psilocybin does
some quick you know comparisons of
similarities and differences so
ssris i didn't realize take apparently
several months to kick in and
specifically with the effects of
neurogenesis creating new neurons in
your brain
in order for your brain to be more
plastic and rewire itself
you know which apparently is an
important part of
curing depression so that may take
several months to can however
you're going to get the side effects
right away
and some of these side effects include
things that could uh worsen your
subjective experience of life so if
you're somebody who's already depressed
right and you take an ssri and you get a
side effect like
some of the side effects now include
um
decreased sexual desire or sexual
performance like you can't get erection
or you know you can't achieve an orgasm
if you do get an erection etc
not fun right
um
anadonia which is kind of the experience
that
nothing is pleasurable to you and part
of that is
i guess ssris
interfere with dopaminergic transmission
so
that is helpful in some ways dopamine
isn't being uh you know transmitted
in the same way so like addiction
might be uh is something that you can
cure with that because
if you're addicted to something it's
hijacking your your dopamine cycle right
and you're reliant on that you're
addicted to that that rush of dopamine
whether it's a substance whether it's
gambling whether it's porn and so an
ssri interferes with that so you're not
getting the same reward from doing those
activities
but you're also not getting the same any
reward from doing
other healthy activities right so it
feels like nothing you do brings you any
pleasure so in the short term if that's
happening you're like man i took these
ssris my depression hasn't been cured
but like now i enjoy even less things so
there's
this connection between ssris and
suicide risk or suicidal ideation
and
leah was trying to break down like well
there's a kind of logical reason for why
these things might happen because you
know in the short term it can create
these negative effects even though
technically they are working over the
long term
uh you might be you know you're dealing
with a pool of people who's already
predisposed maybe to suicidal ideation
because they're depressed and then you
add on this thing that in the short term
you know creates a lull in your
experience of life
versus psilocybin
um
that can actually
both
directly um
targets
serotonin agonism so it goes straight to
you know the the from my understanding
the serotonin receptor
works immediately
and also can start uh creating
neurogenesis immediately and
you know i'll i'm i want to look more
into it but i didn't realize that they
sort of like are working in such similar
ways like the you know the outcome is
like you know we're acting on the
serotonin receptor
and
the psilocybin though does it more
directly because rather than uh
you know prevent the reuptake of your
own serotonin
i believe that the psilocybin molecule
can bind or agonize directly to the
serotonin receptor and therefore can
work immediately interesting stuff i
want to look more into it but
you know that's going to be an ongoing
thing i'd like to eventually experiment
with ssris leo's recommendation was to
me that anybody on youtube should
take ssris to make you
uh more resilient was the word he used
you know so like when people come up
with stuff like you know i look like hgh
santa claus like that doesn't bother me
as much so that would be interesting to
me because yes i do deal with a lot of
online criticism it's mostly unfair it's
mostly hurtful but maybe if i had some
ssris in combination with the mushrooms
who knows you could be looking at a
whole different mark a much happier
person who just doesn't really give a
hoot what people say about them
so yeah while i enjoy micro dosing
mushrooms the nootropic that i always
use every time before my podcast is
still kratom you just can't beat it and
you can't beat the quality that you get
from happy hippo herbals.com
so i want you to go there right now and
use promo code ficboy with three c's to
use 20 off your next purchase and every
single purchase you use after that and
i'll say it again you can't beat the
quality if you haven't tried kratom you
should try it use a small dose you'll
love it and if you already use kratom
why aren't you using the best at happy
hippo herbals.com come on buddy another
thing that a lot of people have been
asking me is mark ooh
where'd you get that shirt from and this
is actually true because people ask me
where did i get this shirt from because
i don't know if you can tell through the
video but this is a really nice feeling
shirt and people notice the quality
difference and i notice it when i wear
it it fits great it feels great it's
breathable it's high quality it's the
type of shirt that you put on you can
wear to a variety of functions right
this would look good like a you know a
holiday or family gathering you can also
wear it out to a bar or something like
that you can even shadow box
in a video like you might have seen on
instagram so
unless you've been on a rock you've been
following me you know i am working with
oak and stone stoneclothing.com
i love oakenstone i love their products
um the the guys who founded the company
are great individuals and
their mission here is simple it's to
make clothes
for guys with athletic physiques and
fill that
gap in the market
that there just isn't a lot of other
people doing in a high quality way this
isn't fast fashion it isn't h m this is
stuff that's built to last it's using
ethically sourced product and it's an
american business that i urge you to
support
and support the podcast go to
oakandstoneclothing.com and use code
hella at checkout for 10 off and follow
them online oakenstoneclothing on
instagram
thanks let's get back to the podcast all
right we're gonna go right into a lot of
people been asking me because it's true
a lot of people ask me a lot of
different things online and sometimes i
am here to provide answers for you
somebody asked me recently hey what's
your split
and i don't have an answer for that um
because i've done it all and currently
i'm kind of doing a mix of things which
i'll get into in a second but i have
done
full body full body circuits uh upper
lower split six days a week so i'm
getting in muscle groups
you know hitting each muscle three times
a week i have done push-pull legs i have
done various bodybuilding splits
including just doing that one muscle a
day i've been doing six day a week
bodybuilding splits where i do um
antagonistic muscles like chest and
bicep back and triceps shoulders and you
know on its own and then legs and then
repeat or maybe shoulders and legs on
the same day
um
and so i've been around the block as far
as that thing and my answer to that
person after explaining all that and
before i get into actually what i'm
doing is
you should make those decisions
through experimentation and also based
on what is going to be sustainable for
you over the long term because
there's no perfect split there's no
perfect diet there are some general
principles
that you have to somehow merge with your
ability to do those things and your
desire to do those things and your
ability to stay consistent
over the course of years because when
you're talking about putting on muscle
which i have to infer from this question
you're asking me about how i lift
weights and how i organize my time in
the weight room and how i break up the
different muscles it's all in service of
this very general goal of like i want to
get more muscular okay
that's not a process that happens in a
month or six weeks or two months
it's a process that happens long term
over the course of years so only through
experimentation will you find what you
generally enjoy doing and i'm somebody
i've found like
i like doing the full body stuff if left
to my own devices because i don't have
to spend that long on any given muscle
group and i've done the bodybuilding
stuff where you do 30 sets of chest or
whatever and i just honestly find that
boring now but as a 14 year old or a 16
year old i thought that was really cool
to like annihilate my pecs until i
couldn't you know flex them anymore and
you're sore for like a week and it was
just like this nice reminder of like yes
i'm working this and this is sore and i
like i feel the correlation between the
work i put in the soreness it reminds me
that i'm growing and
that was cool for me then
but then you grow out of that right mark
ripito that's his famous clip of him
where he's like if you're if you're
training to get sore because you enjoy
that feeling grow up
and it's kind of true like you have to
grow out of that notion of like i didn't
get a good workout unless i'm sore
because you can actually grow without
being sore you know you can do a few
sets per body part and make it intense
and do that several times a week and
have the volume match what you'd
normally do in that you know single
muscle workout and actually grow more
from those repeated ballots that are
much shorter
nowadays what i do actually because i
end up working out with my client paul i
do a lot of single
muscle stuff like we'll spend the whole
day on chest we'll spend the whole day
on back and then also do legs now if
you're doing that if you're doing chest
back and legs you're also kind of
getting shoulders and arms too
indirectly so as long as i add a little
additional volume throughout the week to
those things when i can and sometimes
also like i'll do chest with him in the
morning
and then do chests with brendan the next
day or in the afternoon i'm not opposed
to that it's kind of my my schedule is
unorganized because i'm working on the
other people but it's not the worst
thing in the world you know if you if
you have enough muscle if you have a
certain level of advancement you don't
need to be organized all the time and
you can hit muscles two days in a row or
twice in the same day and it's not gonna
kill you um
i just wouldn't recommend it in the
super long term i would recommend
finding something that you like because
you know
burning yourself out in two months you
could hit a split you know
be super disciplined and
but you hate it and you stick to it and
then at the end of it you're like this
sucks and i hate lifting weights you're
not gonna gain any muscle you're gonna
go right back to normal the person who
over the course of years sticks with
something even if it's three days a week
which is still great for a lot of
naturals three days a week pushable legs
you know or an alternating upper lower
or three days a week full body whatever
it is you don't need to spend that much
time you just need to think about what
could i keep up for five years that's
where the real transformations
come into play
now i don't know if i've done jeff
nippert before i know i've thought about
doing him a lot before but for hella
sick fitness pages i just want to show
you that this is a guy who i send out
links
from his youtube stuff and i'm just
putting his
insta here so you can get a quick feel
of what he looks like
he's a short king
he is you know the asperger's king of
youtube fitness to me because he's
somebody who's
super concerned and super
like organized and concerned with like
the exact science and you know this
study shows that uh the the lat was most
stimulated with a medium grip pulldown
he's going to give you all that type of
information that i don't really give a
[ __ ] about but i will inform myself with
that but know that there's not always
going to be a direct link between
studies and what your results are
because there's a lot of things that
could potentially be wrong with studies
where you're studying undertrained
people you don't know the intensity
level that they're training out there's
all these other variables that it gives
you clues and information but it doesn't
always paint the whole picture
this guy does know what he's talking
about and so if you're looking for more
like what do the studies say about how
to work out in these particular ways or
what more you know what exercises give
more activation quote unquote which is
can kind of be a misnomer because just
because something is activated doesn't
mean it's like stimulated for growth
or that it's you know
it's getting most of the tension in a
workout you know but it provides
some data and some clues and this guy is
kind of
regarded as one of the best people to do
it
i'm bringing this guy up because anytime
people ask me about a split
he has these series of videos on youtube
that are like
you know the best uh you know
five-day whole body workout according to
science the best push-pull legs
according to science the best bro split
according to science so if you look up
jeff nippard and whatever version of a
split you want like push-pull legs you
can get a really really good free
template um of that exact thing that you
want
and then i don't have to write out my
entire workout
you know because people will actually
ask me like hey what are you doing for
diet and workout these days and it's
like you're asking me to like describe
my entire thing and i want to be able to
do that maybe you know a few months ago
i would do that but now i'm just like oh
my god i can't like you know i'm not
going to just like offer a paragraph so
thank you jeff nippert because you are
allowing me
to save a lot of time by just clicking
a link to copy and send to this person
but that does bring me into something
that
i want a little preview for this week's
bro science academy i want to give you a
preview of how i approach for example
the things that i'm doing now when i
have a client i'm doing chest um here's
some general principles that i think
about when i'm doing a single muscle
workout okay we're hitting chest the
basics are gonna be two to five sets per
exercise
to failure or within one to two reps of
failure three to five exercises per
workout so you can see that range is
from the lowest six sets i would still
consider that a workout if you did you
know
three different exercises two hard sets
each you can get a great chest workout
with that
but up to 25 sets if you increase your
volume up to that point you feel like
that's needed because you've been slowly
ramping it up you know and i could
probably handle 25 sets right about now
and it wouldn't be over training for me
um but that would be all you'd need i
wouldn't recommend doing
a 25 set chest workout twice in a week
especially if you're natural and
especially not on a regular basis even
if you are enhanced so the things that i
then think about when i go in because it
changes every time but i use some
general principles i'm coming in and i
typically
am going to start with a barbell
movement
or a heavy dumbbell
movement if i start with incline bench
then i would then go to a flat
dumbbell bench if i start with flat
bench then i would then go to an incline
dumbbell right basic stuff here we're
mixing and matching
because i want to get various angles but
also know that you know
if you're looking to build your upper
chest specifically
just doing incline
stuff whether it's dumbbells or barbells
isn't necessarily sufficient i want to
also get something that's like a smith
machine or a hammer strength machine
really high incline because
you really target your incline either
the upper portion of the chest by coming
from low to high and finishing this
contraction way up here right so there's
a great hammer strength machine that's
an incline that's like it feels a little
bit too high almost or you get on the
smith machine
and
bring it up here and it's at a higher
angle and maybe you bring it higher up
on your chest you're using a lot less
weight you're using a lot more control
but i believe in starting with these
heavy things just to even measure your
strength an incline and flat barbell
bench are a great way to measure your
output and say am i making progress with
my strength if you are chances are your
pecs are getting bigger but then you
want to hit everything else
to focus on hypertrophy
i mix barbells dumbbells i get on
machines
bench machine just a flat bench machine
that's not a hammer strength so it's
just like it's everything's moving at
once
dip machines i really like because
it allows you to sit here and stretch
and there is a component to it that's
less stressful on my shoulders
than doing actual dips if i do do dips
i'm doing heavy dips to start out with
at the beginning of the workout and
that's one of these things like flat
like incline
barbells you want to use weighted dips
as a strength measurement movement and a
primary builder that you can start off
with that wouldn't wait you know three
exercises deep to do weighted dips on
your chest because you're just gonna be
too fatigued your triceps are gonna be
fatigued it's not gonna be the best
thing but if you can get to the point
where you have three plates hanging off
your waist
you know you're probably building
uh some great lower pecs down here right
and you really do
want this full range of motion coming
all the way back here you know finishing
that there finishing here finishing down
there
um and the final thing is to add not the
final thing isolation movements i use
the pec deck
um obviously but i also use dumbbell
flies on flat and incline
i have my own way of doing it
when i
bring my hands down like this i make
sure to open up and i always pause on
flies i don't just sit here and cut like
i don't bounce out of here i wait a
second i feel the stretch and i come up
and with any sort of pec deck the
advantage is that you can also flex here
i always have my chest out because the
real function of the pec is to
wrap around your sternum right so if
you're hunched over like this that's all
shoulders so you always want to have a
big breath a big chest
and
sometimes i'll do a double thing right
here where i go like boom boom i stretch
and then come back and contract and
contract so it's like one two one two
one two
but for me especially because of these
injuries i have to make sure
that
the pain that's in my shoulder isn't
interfering with the firing of the pec
fibers and that helps on a pec deck to
come in here and just make sure the
weight is at the appropriate amount that
i can
squeeze here and activate fibers that
aren't going to be activated on a flat
bench
and then finally a big underrated thing
is to do push-ups
weighted push-ups and deficit push-ups
at the end i finished this off my chest
workout the other day
uh with just getting a pair of dumbbells
and putting my feet up on an elevation
just on a bench not that much but like
10 body weight deficit push-ups
fantastic
also putting
a plate on your back or some sort of
weight on your back and doing a push-up
fantastic and it just engages your pecs
in a way because you can move your hands
around in a way you have this freedom of
movement and hand placement that you
just don't
with a bench press so i feel it in my
pecs more but a lot of people
don't do this kind of stuff for whatever
reason it's not as glamorous but if you
can get you know a really if you can
stack plates on your back and do
push-ups you're gonna be building your
chest
okay can we get on to some hella chef
harley here's a little hack
i have been going nuts
with the poly unsaturated fats
i was a hater i was a doubter hater of
the week is mark harley of course again
because
you know for so many
years i was like oh chase scenes suck
pumpkin seeds what are you doing
flax seeds get out of here hippie i was
actually very cool like anytime somebody
would bring up chia seeds flax seeds or
i was like tell me are you on this train
or not
no and uh you're a hippie
i am a hippie you know but it took me
realizing that like oh you actually
you know number one these are all things
that are going to help your hair growth
out because your hair needs these
kind of fats just
in your diet
you know
it's going to help you formulate healthy
hair polyunsaturated fats and also by
the way these are
more calories than you'd think like a
quarter cup of
pumpkin seeds is 160 calories but you
get
six grams of polyunsaturated fats
two tablespoons is 60 calories not that
bad of this flax seed stuff and you get
three grams of polyunsaturated fats
and chia seeds are the monster here two
and a half tablespoons 150 calories so
it's like you just put this thing in it
seems like nothing but it is you know
it'll add up because i'll eat all these
at once and i've been putting them in my
protein pancakes it actually makes the
pancakes
taste better and it's a better
consistency a little thicker and it's
more filling because again these are
fats
i'm also using these because uh you know
one of these things i'm getting into is
the notion of the difference between
uh
you know animal fats or
saturated fats or you know if you're
getting your fats from fried foods and
less than ideal sources
versus polyunsaturated fats that can
actually be the difference if you're
both eating a calor a calorie surplus
and these two different groups that
you're studying
it turns out that if you have
uh
all your fats are coming from
polyunsaturated like
you're going to gain more muscle than
the other group whoa
and i was shocked by that but i realized
i shouldn't be because it's the same
thing with carbohydrate sources right
it's like yeah man like if this guy's
only eating chips and this guy's eating
brown rice like there's going to be a
difference on your insulin which of
course is going to impact um
you know
the degree to which you gain fat
and
i was just i was playing ignorant before
you know and i fought myself for that
because you get into little routines and
you convince yourself of things all the
time in your life you're like no that's
fine i don't need chia seeds
chia seeds are total [ __ ] right
wrong
now
there's going to be more on that and i
want to this again is from tyent clark
and i'm going to be going
more into his general diet
recommendations because he has a lot of
mind-blowing stuff
how we do it on time do we have time for
this why we can't have nice gyms amongst
other things um
so we got one here then we got a kind of
you know we got a smorgasbord of videos
i don't want okay look at this
boom goes up to dunk it goes all the way
around the rim oh it doesn't make it
boom right in the face and why am i
including this and this way we can't
have nice gems i'm including this
because
basketball is part of the gym right this
is like an outdoor gym
it's so enough that room is so low yeah
and he's still putting it right i just
love those kind of things people get mad
and then you know hit themselves in the
face because you can only get madder
from there right
and then the person who filmed it i
wonder if you know when that happens
like this the guy go please don't post
that yeah
and then it just goes viral i like the
caption too this guy's going places not
to the nba but places
oh my god all right let's go on the next
one again these are these are a little
unconventional
oh [ __ ] look at the cakes on that dog
huh that dog is packing
some peach right there yeah cheeks for
weeks cheeks for weeks let me tell you
i want to buy that dog's booty program
eight weeks to the best doggy buns of
your life
now this one's just it's like i go why
am i including this because it's
impressive athletically look at what
this bear is doing he's a calisthenics
master
he's uh he's basically doing a pull up
on this rope and he's like he's doing
like a ropes course
uh haters will say
this bear has better grip strength than
me
and they'd be right
oh and he's getting with his feet he's
holding himself up and he's actually
getting this little bird house
i wonder if he's going to be
disappointed he's hanging from the
birdhouse yeah i don't even see this
part he's hanging off
oh eddie let's go okay so ultimately
slingshot it at 300 yards in the air
oh my god that's funny and what do we
got here
oh yes this is this reminded me of like
this is like the plot of the happening
by night shyamalan in one 10-second
video
which i didn't see by the way everybody
said it was horrible but it was like you
know when the environment strikes back
and this guy's cutting down a tree
it lands a branch snaps off and flies
all the way through the air and just
nails this guy in the face do you see
that oh yeah you might not see it at
first and i didn't either i'm like i
want like the tree didn't miss a single
throw what does that mean why didn't he
right he's looking right at it and like
the the branch flips through but that is
such a big log i mean it looks like it's
like eight feet long and it just whacks
him
would i be shocked if that guy was now
dead no no uh would i be surprised if he
had major damage to his face that
required reconstructive surgery also no
also now do i really care no because
obviously
he's somebody who just doesn't have any
regard for this tree so why should i
have any regard for his face once again
caption on point the tree chose
vengeance
see i didn't see that before uh good
[ __ ] all right we got one final one here
one two oh
the guy now i know sorry casey i just
queued up a video
where a guy probably breaks his neck and
is paralyzed now and just didn't give a
case any warning because that's the kind
of guy i am
um but i love this kind of stuff i mean
i have to assume that like
i don't know for a fact but i assume
he's not paralyzed um
but i love stuff like this because it's
like
if i were to do a backflip off the ropes
like i think i'd have it down you know
what i mean it's like i think i'd be
like i'd work through the steps of like
i know what it feels like to do a
backflip and
know exactly and i've taken like i used
to take diving as a kid not that i'm an
expert like but i know what it feels
like to do a flip and and the process of
working through more difficult movements
like doing a backflip of a high dive or
doing a gainer which you know requires
you to like i slammed my back a lot on
the water and eventually got it um
but
i don't know really if this guy's trying
to do two flips it looks like he's
trying to do it i only saw it once and
i'm not going to watch that again but it
looked like he was yeah so that's my
feeling on it but then again it's like
if you're gonna do two first of all
there's no reason to do two flips like
you're not in the wwe
there's literally no stakes on the line
and uh the consequences of missing that
are not that you might like
you know
get a red mark on your back in the water
it's your neck's gonna be broken so why
would you do that for this i don't know
i guess it's just always this
you know and same thing with like we
talked about like skating and
rollerblading it's like
there comes a point where you as you
mature you're like
there's no point in doing this yeah you
know like there's there's
the stakes aren't high enough there's
nobody watching you um you know this
isn't going to be
paid off in any way that makes it in any
way worth the risk
of
injuring your spinal cord permanently
but
now that i'm
on the thick boy network
having my own podcast i feel like
i feel like i could do maybe maybe
today's the day that i'm gonna i've been
talking about doing a backflip
and
okay
okay yeah
okay wish me luck casey